um so I am oven Indra I work at hello
fresh as a software engineer
and today I'm gonna talk about building
reliable web applications using test
driven development
using fast API and salary
in my day-to-day job I mostly use flask
fast API salary a little bit of react to
build internal tools
um
and today uh our goal is to yeah my goal
is to
introduce these concepts with the help
of test driven development two years ago
when I joined the company I didn't know
much about test driven development
and when I learned about it I was quite
the concept was a little bit
counterintuitive for me
and since then I have fell in love with
it and I hope I can convey the same
feeling to you
for some reason my
next button is not working
um
a little bit of yeah hopefully yeah all
right so let me begin with the
acknowledgments to the creators of
celery the community around it and to
the python community in general
um since I'm not sure given that it's
the last take that everyone will you
remain awake till the end of the talk
let me present the key takeaways right
in the beginning
bad
the
goal really is that the test event
development is one of the best tools or
methods to design your system as it
makes the feedback cycle faster
for Designing anything or improving
anything in general what you need the
most is feedback and that's what test
driven development brings to the table
faster feedback the second takeaway is
kind of gonna be that dependency
injection is gonna make your code more
testable and most I mean although we
will discuss specific case of fast FBI
and celery how to test them how to write
them but these are the kind of two broad
principles which apply to any software
testing in general
um
coming to the outline of the talk
um we'll go a little small introduction
of what tdd is what test driven
development is how to set up our
development environment using docker how
to build a API with fast API and then we
will offload some of the job to salary
long-running tasks some conclusion and
further resources
um I will try to do some live demo let's
see how that goes
um
so this is what astonished me that when
I learned first about it that you have
to start by writing a failing test well
if you write a test of course it's going
to fail because there is no code to
support it so that is the first step of
DDD and then you try to write just
enough code to make it pass you don't
Implement other features which you have
in mind you might have thought of so
many features which you want in your app
but no you are not allowed to write any
of it only just that much which makes
your test case pass
and then the most important thing is to
refactor both your test as well as your
code
um and and just keep doing it over and
over again until your software is kind
of complete uh till your all the tickets
which your product manager has given you
is complete so that's the
that's the summary of TTD
um then but but why should we write the
test first this was really astonishing
to me and it it is a better
documentation uh not really I mean if
you write your test afterwards it still
serves as documentation it doesn't
change anything
does it reduce the cost of fixing defect
uh also not because if you write
afterwards
still the cost is lesser when you visit
like five months later the effect is the
same really the code quality
does it improve maybe there is a maybe
here because of the feedback cycle but
really I I would stress again that the
faster feedback is the is the key here
at least in my experience
um also I don't want to say that tdd is
the Silver Bullet here there are
limitations like there is a little bit
of overhead
involved learning curve is also there
because no matter how much I tried in
the beginning I couldn't write test
first it was just a matter of habit to
write the code and you know build do
something useful uh you know with your
time
and really it works very well if you use
other extreme programming techniques
like peer programming code reviews
Etc
um if I mean I I can't talk much about
the theory because well I don't know but
also because there are better books and
resources available for it
the first book by Kent back excellent
book also the second one these two are
Classics but they are both have examples
in Java if you don't like them the third
one is exclusively for python I strongly
encourage all three books
um yeah so what is the goal I mean I
don't want to present just the slides I
really want to get going with with some
code here and um what will what are we
trying to do today we are trying to
implement an order service what does the
order service do it takes some input
some payload from a front-end or another
service
ticks and tries to
do some processing which our
stakeholders have asked right we will
come to what we do in just a moment
let's briefly see what
front-end payload will be and what
information product service gives you
know so this is a micro service
landscape there is some front-end
running which will send a payload to
order service and it will try to fetch
information about the product from
another service product service and we
will try to see how that goes right
so this front-end service can give you
the name of the customer the email some
shipping info payment info and what are
the items the customer has ordered right
along with any discount code and the
quantity yeah and the product service is
kind of
yeah it has the the ID which which the
customer has sent you the product ID
there is matches with ID the name of the
product the currency the price all the
valid discounts you know description
whether it's in stock or not things like
those products typical product service
right
um but what we want the order service to
do well I don't have a lot of time so I
can't build everything
um but we want the order service to
calculate the total price something
pretty simple we don't want the front
end to send it because well users will
exploit it right and they can just send
arbitrary number as total price possibly
zero so we want the calculation to
happen in the order service
and just return on confirmation ID that
well your order has been placed and send
an email to the customer saying that
well the order is placed and if the
payment goes through then the item might
be shipped
um so this is the overall feature
request which we have got now we need to
break it down into pieces
um
of how we can achieve it right and then
we will try to demo it one by one
first
the order service need to talk to
product service right
um
for that
we will build a class which can get an
item by using its ID
um since we have to build an API
um we need to deploy a fast API
application just with a health
checkpoint
endpoint which checks itself and on
order endpoint to process the order
we'll do some refactor afterwards
um deploy the salary worker and offload
the emailing task to salary worker
usually you wouldn't offload emailing
tasks to salary worker probably
background task from Fast API is more
suited to it but in this example I mean
we will just offload it to salary
so okay
let me
start with the demo
and I have to move my
vs code into the other screen
okay this is going to be a bit
challenging because
can't see my own screen
but let's see let's see let me Zoom is
is it legible like everybody can can can
everybody read it
yeah
but I think it's too
too big so maybe we we decrease it
the width right so as I said we start I
mean I have set up the virtual
environment and everything because of
course we won't have enough time and
let's start with just one test
the test is pretty simple there is uh
product
we are planning to build a product
service right and product service is
returning everything as a dictionary and
we really don't want to work as
dictionary so what the product service
is going to do is just convert that
dictionary
in into an object right that's all the
assert statement is saying here right
that I want
whatever the output is coming from
product service I want to convert it
into and product object right and this
object would look something like this
this is from pedantic it has all the
appropriate props all the appropriate
properties
and the discount is essentially a list
of discounts
and we want to assert and in the end
that the ID is the same we could do more
and we also want to
be sure that this counter also in the
right format
um yeah I mean of course if we run this
test now we will get the
okay
this is getting a little bit challenging
okay let's hope my
and of course it will fail and here what
is important it fails in a specific way
it says that we cannot import product
service because it's not implemented yet
so
yeah okay even before we go there maybe
we should first take a look at the
um
maybe we should take a look at the how
it looks like the
how our product service looks like
if I click on it and there is an API
running how this has been set up if I
take a look at my
Docker file here I have set up a small
wire mock which mimics a product service
so I'm not going to in detail with how
this wire mock Works suffice to say that
it will return for some given valid I
IDs it will return the return the
description of product and all I want to
do is convert this Json into into a
python object which I can play with
um yeah so
what I can do is I can just write
an init method and a git by ID
to to enable that right I can make a
Json I can make a request to get the
object and I can just convert it into an
object and that would
that should make the test pass
yeah
um usually it's not enough to
write just a passing test probably we
also want to test that an invalid object
throws up an error right and in this
case I want to raise a value error if
some invalidate ID is passed in
um currently if we run the test of
course it will fail
um yeah I I get this error I can try to
read it and understand what it does I I
mean ideally I would put a break point
and would try to understand what's going
on in this case I just know that
yeah the service is turning 404 and
it's unable to to response dot Json
um
so
yeah
what I can do here in this particular
case is whenever I
um so even before we actually implement
this maybe I go ahead and
go with the refactor what I said about
refactoring so we have made from red to
Green Let's refactor it I don't want to
make a request in this function
otherwise it's doing too many things I
probably want to have another hidden
function which
makes the request
and let me disable this this is the
problem with demoing
so I I have refactored it in a way that
instead of making requests directly in
this function now I am using get
function
and if I run it the test still continues
to pass and as soon as I
now I try to build a new feature saying
that it should throw the value error
when an invalid invalid ID is provided
right and in this case whenever 404 is
reached
I can try to
do this right
and now the test passes
again I have not shown the whole path
um
because ideally
what would have happened is this product
service should not have come as an
argument I should have
built it right but now I see there is
some code duplication going on between
our two tests
and whenever there is a code duplication
it's most likely it points to that we
need to refactor it out and for this pie
test provides us
um I mean we could just Define it up
here to be honest this product service
variable but the I the preferred way in
pi test is to write what is called
fixtures and the wave fixture works is
that function you can define a function
either up here and Mark it as fixture
like so
with a decorator or
you can put it in a special file called
conf test in this case this function
product service will be evaluated before
it's called right and that's what you
were seeing earlier that I can you know
that I can run this fixture sort of here
um and I can
put the same fixture here get rid of
this
completely
and
all right and I hope that even after my
refactor the code continues to work so
that's what we have done here uh red
green and refactor cycle so we have
refactor a little bit of the code and
um but during the refactor cycle it's
super important that all our existing
tests should continue to pass
so that was a simple demonstration of
building our our
product class and if we go to the next
plan that was to deploy a fast API
application with an Health endpoint now
how do we do it in a test driven manner
sort of
so before writing any other test
this is what we want to achieve right
again there are some fixtures being used
here but since I have introduced
fixtures probably I can already say that
you can imagine that somewhere I have
this fixture hopefully here yeah test
client which comes from Fast API which
you can use
and the idea is that
um
yeah
that this test client is almost like
request object you can do dot get in it
and I want to assert that status quo is
200 and this is equal to this is the
message right
this is what we want to run the problem
is I don't want to run fast API in
directly on my terminal I want to run it
in a dockerized environment
so I what I want to be able to do is to
say Docker compose exact
and name of the service let's assume we
will call it back end and Pi test and
really
this this path right so what it
essentially means I'm telling Docker to
run inside the backend container Pi test
and this of course it will say that the
service backend doesn't exist and with
this error message I will go to Docker
and I will
sort of
enable it right and then I will go ahead
and implement the the health endpoint
I'm not gonna walk through the entire
process here but
um
because writing uh
health
yeah now I'm getting 404
and I can
imagine that in my API
are really not even there just in my
main I have to
Define it right create a fast API
instance and just return it and then it
should pass right so that brings us to
our second point right so I mean again
we have gone in a test driven manner we
have first written what we expected we
expect a health endpoint with
simple
um
payload and that's what we are getting
right
now the third step is to build an order
endpoint to process the orders right now
if we see it this checklist is what we
want to do right we want to calculate
the total price we want to get a
confirmation ID and we want to send an
email and we want to achieve all three
so that is what our tests should
say right that given a
an order data
like a payload which we saw in the
presentation earlier
um okay this is not yeah let's say that
first one
given a an order data
um
I want an email service so this is
probably
Let's ignore it for a moment
let's say that we have this order data
and
I want to go to an order endpoint
provide this order data and the Response
Code should be 201 I probably don't want
to do anything else at this stage
and I I just want to
Implement a bare minimum of things
right and if I go to
My Views now
I have
introduced
so
um I I would go ahead and in a very
painful manner I I will just I trade I
will I will use the product service
let's forget the email service at the
moment we will use the product service
and
um
calculate the total total cost by
looping through all the all the products
and applying all the discounts sort of
right but even before implementing
actually
we have not
shown the red stage yet we should have
first
try to
run this test and it would have um
of course failed
and if you see it says essentially that
the order service is not implemented
well we went ahead of ourselves
uh
tint
yeah so
so if you see uh in in this one what we
are doing is we are getting the order
data
and we are calculating the cost and we
are just returning the order response
in in fast API we
provide type hints for our payload as
well as our response and that ensures
that our data is validated
so we will have to we must Define how
our
input should look like and how our
response should look like and this is
all based on type hints
so you ex I mean this is exactly the the
payload which we saw earlier right the
ID the customer name and uh and and list
of all the items and in the response we
only think I want to add is the total
cost so it gets the order data and it
tries to
return the total cost
yeah
um
and once we have done all the
calculation
so
yeah
what what we want to achieve here is to
return the total cost
and
let's see if we get some more errors
it says API router is not defined that
should come from
fast API
um
and now it says order service is not
defined
[Music]
um
yeah that might be happening because
in the service I might have imported the
order service
which is not yet implemented
[Music]
um
so
ah
and this one I already removed it
so
yeah
um
but now it says
no tests
right so let's see
um
what I want is
this test over here
um
I definitely don't want to run this test
just yet
uh
if I
okay
so it says here
okay probably I have overwritten it
in the pi test dot ini
not sure
sorry
ah
so yeah I just copied the wrong path I
guess
and now it fails in the right way
um
yeah so it says that 404 and this is
just because I have not imported the the
router uh in the
in in the right place the problem is I
can't see my own screen and I have to
see the other screen so I can't
see everything super clearly
unfortunately
um and yeah
so if I go to main Dot py
should exist somewhere
yeah so this router needs to be added
and imported
and then it then it passes right but
we had decreased the scope of the test
quite a lot we were not checking if the
emails is being sent so the thing is
we don't want to use a real email
service to send an email during the test
of course so we would like to mock it
so
um
and how we can mock it
um so
the first API comes with this depends
which marks it as a dependency which can
be overridden during our test
and
what I can say is that I create a mock
email service and I override the real
email service with this mock one
and then
I
just assert
that the send email has been called once
if you want you can also assert that it
has been called with the that it has
been called with the right parameters if
you want and so on and of course if you
run the test
um
that should fail
because and it says
if you see here it says
um
that it oh it says it does not have the
ID
so I mean this is of course wrong we
want the confirmation ID so we would say
the confirmation ID should exist rather
and now it says the mock to be called
one once but it was called zero times
and then if you enable this small line
here when you actually send the email
now it that should pass right and
similarly the total cost calculation
but this would not be the preferred way
of doing it because we really don't want
to put business logic in our
in our views in our router so ideally we
would want to create an order service
and then send that
um and and and use that to do the
calculus
do total cost calculation
[Music]
just like we are sending email via an
email service
so the the real way of doing it real
test might be to use the same order data
and
yeah and and use order service to do it
but I due to lack of time let's not
refactor it just yet because I think I
have run completely out of time as
pointed out by the the chairman so I
will stop it but I will share the slides
and the repo with you I hope that I have
not disappointed you all with all the
technical glitches and inconveniences so
sorry for letting you down but I will
share the GitHub repo and the slide in
the in in the Channel with you all thank
you very much
[Applause]
so we still have a couple of questions
um when would you use salary for long
running tests instead of fast API
background services or
who we I'm sorry so when would you use
celery for long running tests instead of
fast API backend Services
um yeah so background Services works
just fine for small tasks but if it's
really wrong running I don't want to do
it in a small thread I would rather
offload it to an independent virtual
machine in a salary that that would be
better at least in my opinion okay yeah
next question how can I write the test
for a method if it does not exist yet
yeah so I mean you would write the test
assuming certain API in mind and the
advantage you will get is that you will
assume this is how my function should
look like
so if the function is not good to use
you know if it's not very easy to use
you won't be able to write your test
easily and that would improve the API of
the test you are going to write
yeah let's do one more question when are
you in the middle of a project how would
you recommend to switch to tdd
uh that's a tricky one I mean first you
should write enough test coverage for
the existing code base a little bit at
least and then from the new functions
you might try to use tdd but it might be
hard on on a legacy code base to be
honest I have tried it and it's really
hard
to yeah okay thank you very much thank
you